today we're talking about how farmers
use Google Cloud women's equality day
vertical Auto scaling and the cloud hero
cup I'm Debbie Cabrera and welcome to
this week in Cloud where we serve you
the lowest latency news
want to learn how Farmers navigate
weather patterns that affect supply
chain issues with the help of cloud
learn how bushel helps over 2 000 grain
receiving locations across the United
States and Canada by utilizing the tools
and scalability of Google Cloud check
out the blog to learn more recently we
celebrated women's equality Day by
recognizing the powerful women and
movements that have paved the way for us
while continuing to work to break
barriers for the women of the Next
Generation we as both internal googlers
and our Google Cloud innovator Champion
Community what women's equality Day
means to them take a look at the blog to
hear their responses and learn more
about women's equality day dataflow
prime a new Next Generation serverless
no Ops Auto tuning platform for your
data processing needs on Google Cloud
recently launched a new industry First
Resource optimization technology
vertical Auto scaling automatic
medically scales worker memory and
determines the right worker
configuration for your job there's no
extra cost to use vertical Auto scaling
as dataflow Prime jobs continue to be
billed based on resources it consumes
find out how you can try it out for
improved resource optimization and cost
savings by reading the full blog post
and keep an eye out for a video coming
soon recently Google Cloud held the
inaugural Cloud hero cup a competition
designed to help teams learn new
technology the cloud hero cup is a
gamified learning competition between
University it teams that uses Google
Cloud skills boost to test and expand
their knowledge of Google Cloud this
year's challenges use kubernetes skills
and infra skills games to help teach how
to solve common challenges
congratulations to University of
California Riverside for being our first
winners of the cloud hero cup what
challenges will be next and who will
hold the cup in the future find out more
details on the blog if you want to read
more about these announcements or see a
full list check out the link any
thoughts or ideas leave us a comment or
tweet us we'll see you in the cloud